I hear you have a taxidermy collection
that fascinates me I want to hear about
that I have a taxidermy horse oh you
stopped a member of a boy band and you
have a taxidermy collection I think we
know where JC is now about you will one
day we're in California everything's
legal here people can smoke pot on their
unicycles it's all fine
big people here so what what do you what
kind of taxidermy
a horse you've actually German I love
three-week-old died of natural causes a
miniature horse and I have a I have a
chick who I just got her name's Linda
well she's not alive but her name would
have been Linda I have a an owl named
Beatrix and for now I'm calling the
police
[Laughter]
we have the cool we have the coolest
taxidermy - animal of all time that
we've used in our show throughout the
years of all time it's a screeching
raccoon with a jetpack
you do not yeah take a look at this
video clip it's the greatest
it just it goes in circles yeah would
you like that I will give it to you
I will give it to you here on the air
your own taxidermy background
[Applause]
no I'm not gonna shut up it's fantastic
isn't it great who did this
let's not talk about that yeah we're not
in heat niches yeah and he died a
natural death yeah obviously yeah can I
keep him
yes I'm giving that what do you think
this is and this is for you and cut take
it would you like me to hold him for you
I assume it to him yeah can't be sure go
out on the highway and get another one
yeah that's the kind of show we have
yeah that's the kind of show we have I
don't know he's maybe he's not well done
what do you mean you're being critical
of the gift I just gave you you just
said I love taxi girl like what I happen
to have oh thank you I see it floor
she's not wrong yeah really
it really is marginally yes I think you
are a good actress
[Applause]
[Music]
that's yours that's yours to keep and
now we have let me make a hat out of
them you know what I love now we have a
clip of your movie that we're gonna
throw to and I don't know how that goes
from this but we're just gonna do it
then the movies called gone anything we
need to know about this clip I am
threatening the cops which I would never
do in real life but it calls for it
right it's a movie oh it's a movie from
your real life I didn't really set it up
well but it's um it's a it's a fun movie
and it won't fun it's a scary movie and
I had fun doing it and I'm talking to
the cops and you're holding a dead
raccoon let's take a look from gone hey
if my sister dies it's your fault I bet
that's Molly right now hey is Molly with
you no why I'm at the police station so
I'll call you back she's not with her
boyfriend that's because she might have
two of them did you ever think of that
look Joe why don't you just go home you
know get some sleep I'll sleep but he's
dead
you
[Applause]